gazprom's announcement that it is
unilaterally stopping gas deliveries to
certain eu member states is another
provocation from the kremlin
but it comes as no surprise
that the kremlin uses fossil fuels to
try to blackmail us
this is something the european
commission has been preparing for in
close coordination and solidarity with
member states and international partners
our response will be immediate
united and coordinated
first we will ensure that gazprom's
decision
has the least possible impact on
european consumers
today member states met in the gas
coordination group
poland and bulgaria updated us on the
situation
both poland and bulgaria are now
receiving gas from their eu neighbors
and this shows first of all the immense
solidarity among us but it also shows
the effectiveness of past investments
for example in interconnectors and other
gas infrastructure
second
we will continue our work to ensure
sufficient gas supply and storage in the
medium term
our action plan we power eu will help to
significantly reduce our dependency on
russian fossil fuels
already this year
we have as you know
also reached an agreement with the
united states
to provide additional lng imports this
year and the following ones
and we are working hand-in-hand with our
member states to secure alternative gas
supplies from other partners too
in the longer term
repower eu will also help us move to a
more reliable secure and sustainable
energy supply today the kremlin failed
once again
in his attempt to sow division among
member states
the era of russian fossil fuel in europe
is coming to an end
europe is moving forward on energy
issues
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign